yeah let me um put rolo in the spotlight
here first
because i got a question for you so okay
you know like you've been married the
longest obviously you got the longest
long-term relationship
25 years you know it's been successful
for you so
question i have for you you know since
the topic is can a bad marriage you know
shorten a man's life is
one of the most important things that
we've talked about is maintaining frame
right and how important that is so i'm
wondering
how often does the godfather himself
roll up tomosi of the rational male book
series need to check
himself when he's in his long-term
relationship and he's like oh i
don't want to send that text or i don't
want to say that or i shouldn't respond
that way because that's going
that's not going to be conducive to
mental point of origin
and the success of this marriage i don't
know i don't gosh i don't think i've
ever from the last like or
when was the last time you had to check
yourself well okay so
let me let me explain a few things here
first of all it'll be 25 years
uh in the middle of july um of those 25
years i think i've had a smartphone for
maybe
10 of them maybe 12 i don't know like
when when did we when did we start like
introducing those
yeah yeah exactly um
so as far as checking myself um
i can count on the fingers of one hand
how many times i've had an
actual fight with my wife like that's
lasted longer than like
you know half a day uh my wife is
actually
pretty good in the sense that she checks
herself as well and i know if women who
are going to hear this going to go oh my
gosh she must be like
got her under his dumb bro you know he's
a he's a tyrannical
you know tyrannosaurus right um
no
that's not how it works um it's usually
because we have
an understanding of like what our
effective roles are now remember
when i got married way back in 1996
um it was it was a different thing like
i wasn't like the red pill roll of
tamasi that i am today right
um so but i i will say this
is that and i've said this before people
like throw rocks at me when i say this
but
a good relationship is effortless a good
marriage is effortless
um if you want good kid like what is um
good marriages create good kids
right i mean you got to you've got to be
the guy that's going to be right there
all the time for you you've got to be
the a good parent no no doubt
but you also have to be self-concerned
enough to know that
sometimes the decisions that you make
are going to be very unpopular with your
wife and your kid or whatever
but they're actually what's best for
them in the long term
most guys have that self-doubt they
don't they'll be like well
i don't want to i don't want to make the
wrong decision because if i do that i'll
lose my wife and i lose my kids
yeah because they're in that mode of
constant qualification
whereas if you have frame and you've
started out with frame and i like what
what um
what sterling was saying is like that
frame is established between the time
you first have sex
with her and the second time or maybe
the third time that you do
carrying that frame over or not losing
it that is the
you you're going to start your long-term
relationship with the frame that you
establish before you're in that
relationship and
she's constantly testing that frame
right yes she early on anyway
early on anyways and then once once it's
like i think that once women sort of
like settle into
a marriage or a relationship and then
they know what to expect from you
and if what they're expecting from you
is alpha leadership if they're
like my my wife's um my wife's father
is very much an alpha male old school
old texas guy right i mean the guy is
very much alpha and that's what she
expected from me from the beginning like
i've told this story before
whenever i would go out on a date with
my wife and we were taking her car she
would hand me the keys to her car
and i was the one who was expected to
drive her car to wherever we were going
on our particular date or whatever it
was we were doing
and that right there was sort of what
set the frame and the tone for a
relationship because that's what she
expects of me
she expects me to drive the car she she
uh
told me i mean i didn't realize it then
but really that act that symbolism
was i trust you with my life here's the
cars here's the keys to my car
drive my car to wherever we're going to
go you're the you're the one who's in
the head ship of this whole
situation and this is where we're going
to go guys are going to go well it's
different for you rollo blue blue blue
no it's establishing that frame and
living out that frame
so when guys say oh we're a roller i
would i
pity rollo because he has to game his
wife all the time just like you're
saying like
if i get a test from my wife it's
not like i go hmm
let me look at my notes here a lot of
notes
uh youtube to find answers
[Laughter]
right yeah exactly that's that's not how
it works okay it's a
says page 92 yeah it's
second nature to me right it's like it's
not like an act anymore it's who i am
the game right
it's who i am and what i'm what i'm
going to do when guys like say
when guys hit me up and they go like oh
how do you be alpha how do you if you're
asking me how to be alpha you're
you it has to be i just call it zen but
it has to you have to be
that you have to be the game you have to
be that you have to internalize it
it has to become part of your
personality it has to be
your second nature and when i say that
it really rubs women
the wrong way because they think that
i'm trying to brainwash guys it's like
no
i'm giving them what you want actually
eventually you want a good
successful healthy fun you know awesome
relationship where you're having sex and
you're really in love with each other
and you're good for your kids and you're
good for each other
i'm trying to give guys that so that you
can have what it is that you actually
think that you don't
maybe you don't need know that you need
it but that's what you really want
and so when when i say you know like if
my wife gives me a test it's not
that i don't get tests i do it's
just that i pass them
by not thinking about how to pass them i
just default to sort of my red pill
awareness my red pill nature
so when i have these conversations or
it's like oh we really need to move or i
really like this house in cape coral i
really like this place over here
i'm just like i i know where we're going
with that and it's like no that's not
going to satisfy you i'm not going to
make decisions based on
like because you fell in love with a new
house or you fell in love with a new
place or you want to get you want to get
a new pet right
like that kind of stuff it's like i have
to be the the one who's who's going to
pull the trigger
you know i can make an emotional
decision or i can make a rational
decision
and it's like defaulting to what's going
to to
fit the bet you know what what's best
for the family and i don't think enough
guys do that because they think
in terms of like egalitarian equalism
right they think oh well
even steven you know she got to decide
last time so i get to decide this time
and usually it's guys who are just end
up supplicating all the time
and the reason why they won't take
authority or they are afraid to
experiment in their relationships is
because if they do
and things go south then they could be
divorced or their wife will hold out on
them because they're their only source
of sex
there's all all kinds of like leverage
that most the average beta male
sort of married guy has to contend with
so it's
again that's why these guys in this
article that you're just
quoting here it's like that's why
they're unhealthy because they're
constantly trying to figure out they're
trying to uh
they're trying to resolve the quest the
mystery of women right
a lot of that comes from religion too
yeah and religion as well
well the religious i mean that um study
with the scientists was cited from
israel right and that's also
embedded in jewish religion isn't it
yeah yeah definitely abrahamic religions
for sure now
anyways but it's uh you have to remember
that for
uh for modern religions to thrive right
now if they
depend on monogamy because if they don't
have that woman
in in the church if they don't have like
remember women don't earn
as much as men but they spend more than
men so
they still need those women that's why
there's like ministries for single
mothers
and ministries for single women and
stuff and they'll blame it on men for
not
picking up the responsibility which is
their biblical godly responsibility to
do so
but what they're i mean from a practical
perspective from the latent purpose of
the whole thing
it's because those guys are going to
probably earn more money
that means more tithe checks more more
kids more whatever
i'm not saying it's bad for society but
let's look at
what the mechanics are of monogamy
because
most modern like judeo-christian
religions anyways any
anything like that is dependent on even
even you could even make the case for
islam right now even if you got four if
you're if you're rich enough to have
four wives you're probably rich enough
to be contributing to the church
so there's a there's a an economic
aspect that goes along with that too
ryan same question to you man you're
coming up on a decade i wasn't gonna let
you off the hook on this one
all the time dude check yourself all the
time well not that
like every time you do something you
have to take some self-reflection every
now and then the girl will get
like you know get mad they always get
mad and flows coming whatever reasons
you want to do
and then sometimes you kind of aren't
paying attention so you get mad back but
then you just check yourself i'm with
rolo
like i think it's 12 year anniversary
coming up now i can
count on one hand the amount of like
actual fights where i was literally mad
to where one of us wanted to leave the
house because
and even then in retrospect when i look
at those outside of the emotions they
weren't really of very much consequence
either
but that's the thing with this it's not
you know roll always says i am the game
and then idiots always like well that
just means roll thinks he's hot
it's like no it's not it
it's you have your life and it's gonna
go the way it goes
and then whatever happens around that is
not my concern like case in point like
i'm not married we did common law
in canada they have the wonderful thing
well you live together good enough
tomorrow
yeah got it but it was again my
brother's the same way he's with a girl
right now he's about to have a kid
they never got married but that's just
because that's in our frame we watched
our parents divorce
like my mom's divorced twice absolutely
brutal destroyed everybody
a lot of kids a lot of issues but we're
just kind of like well
i'm not doing that because there's
nothing in it for me and that's like the
marriage approach everybody always takes
it that's what i hate too when the
marriage is like
well you have to be married and you're
trying to talk people out of it's like
no no no
give me a good reason to do things that
aren't in my best interest
and i think once you approach things
from that like i'm
more than happy to sacrifice myself for
some greater good but if you don't make
the case to me
it's not my job to make the case i'm not
going to light myself on fire to keep
other people warm because
no good deed goes unpunished and then it
sounds high and noble but you play it
out in normal relationships that tends
to be how
it plays out and that's why there's less
fights it's like like same with rollo
she could fight on this but she knows
i'm not going to buckle if i've you know
if i've said my piece and that's it like
all right that's the way it is
and i either have to learn to accept it
or move on and more often than not she
doesn't want to move on thank god
but that's really it and it's as hard as
you want to make it you know
you